all das was ihr hier seht habe ich nicht
irgendwie im Internet gekauft oder so
sondern bei Otto bulletproof abgeholt
denn ich habe ein Video von ihm gesehen
Samstag ist wir soweit wir machen
lagverkauf vor Super Bowl also für alle
die jetzt richtig Bock drauf haben und
sagen sich hey wir schauen Superbowl wir
lieben Football können sich eindecken
Samstag 12 bis 16 Uhr das machen wir
natürlich Leute wir begeben uns jetzt
auf dem Weg zu Otto erst vor Ort und
dann decken wir uns mal mit allem ein
was er so leckeres hat ihr wisst ich
liebe eigentlich alles was aus Amerika
kommt deshalb los geht's los geht's ich
bin wirklich gespannt was uns hier
erwartet ne weil ich glaube das ist
wirklich eine riesenfma die der Otto da
hat und normalerweise kann man da ja
auch einfach nicht hinspazieren sondern
wie im tiktok gesehen habt ist halt
jetzt dieser offene Verkauf wir sind ein
bisschen früher da das wird
wahrscheinlich keiner da sein aber ja
schauen wir mal schauen wir mal GU mal
hier um die Ecke ist schon das
Schild
hallo
hallo oh Liquid das das Wasser ne ja
schmeckt das irgendwie besonders
wahrscheinlich nicht oder du kannst das
schmeckt tatsächlich sehr gut was kann
das Wasser das ist einf also das hier
ist jetzt flavt aber der Grundansatz den
ich kenne ist dass die Leute einfach
Wasser in Dosen gefüllt haben damit die
Leute die Wasser trinken sich nicht
schlecht fühlen m genau also pass auf
von weiten denkst du doch das ist jetzt
hier irgendwie für Event Bier oder
irg so und das ist halt einfach so
kannst auf Heavy Metal Konzert gehen und
i denkt ja klar jetzt schraubt sich ein
doseer rein oder Zehen dabei das ist nur
Wasser und die haben eine irre
Erfolgsgeschichte
hingelegtfassbareolgeschichte ja da s
auch dran das überlegen mit aufzunehmen
das schauen wir mal was du so ja wir
haben ein Lager gibt auch noch eins dazu
ja und hier hast du eigentlich alles was
wir haben machen nürlich nichts für
Endkunden ne weil viele mal sagen also
ich hatte früher mein Endkundengeschäft
Webshop food for dann gibt's auch noch
machen nur noch Großhandel das heißt
eine Metro findest die Artikel in
manchen REW und edicaa aber ansonsten
kann das ja durch eine simple Idee ne
ich war hat Übung mit Amerikanern damals
gehabt den falsch springen durfte in der
Base Einkaufen in amstein so und dann
dachte ich ja komm ich neh das mit Hause
und ich trinke kaum Alkohol Bier ist so
gar nicht meins und hatte Bier
mitgenommen weil ich bring mein Jungs
immer aus der alten Heimat immer Bier
nachdem wo ich auf Übungsplatz war oder
auf dem Leergang oder so hab gesagt he
hier amerikan Bier schmeckt voll super
weil das SE leicht schmeckt müsst
probieren dieprobiert gesagt kannst du
nicht saufen schmeckt wie Wasser habe
ich damals gesagt komm ich probier auf
eBay zu verkaufen da war ich 21 und so
hat das angefangen erst auf Ebay richtig
ordentlich dann direkt dreibach gemacht
ja voll also das ging wirklich ich hab
nürlich jeden Euro reingepumpt hab dann
mein alttagsauto verkauft mir einen
alten Vito geholt kaprigen aber der
konnte Tonne laden da bin ich rüber
fahren flogen in die USA Lieferanten
gesucht weil die haben nicht auf Mails
reagierten gar nichts weil die gesagt
haben
keine Ahnung wer das da ist jetzt haben
wir eigentlich glaube ich ein cooles
Sortiment was man Großhandel verkaufen
ich weiß das sorgt manchm für Diskussion
man sagt ja auf der einen Seite
Naturschutz und Tieren oder auch
Nachhaltigkeit denke ich schon immer
wieder drüber nach gar keine Frage aber
auf der anderen Seite Leute verstehen
nicht h mitarbeiterplätze dran klar so
dann kann man den Zuschauer ein ja komm
vorbei kündige all für mich auch keine
Option ich hab cooles Team was aber ganz
viele JRE aufgebaut ist wie lange machst
du das jetzt hier alles schon fast 20
Jahre jetzt nicht ganz 19 erst be 19 ich
weiß noch bei mir in meiner heimatstad
schaffenburg gab es immer so ein kleines
Ladengeschäft 40 50 madrmer vielleicht
hast du die auch beliefert Danis corner
ja ein Kunde von uns siehst du mal Grüße
gehen raus und da bin ich immer hin und
habe so richtig so geguckt boah das will
ich mal probieren das will probieren mit
Taschengeld ne und jetzt stehe ich hier
heute im Lager und wir können uns mal
umgucken was wir alles mal so probieren
Kön durch Probieren also wir haben alles
mögche da du kannst dich eigentlich
austoben ich sehe schon meinen Kryptonit
Fanta grape boah so geil wie oft habe
ich schon so enttäuscht irgendwie auch
in Amsterdam oder so so eine lila Fanta
gesehen greift dahin und dann ist es
kassist das ist einfach nur die pure
Enttäuschung weil Fanta grape ist mein
Traum ich liebe das auf dann holen wir
noch mal so ein
Rollwagen es sieht wirklich alles eins
zu eins identisch aus pickle lemon lime
Waterman ich hab hoffe ja ich habe
Pickel dabei gerne ja ich mag alles ich
hab es jetzt erst gecheckt das ist ein
Roulette ist R ja du kannst immer was
anderes so t in meinem
Leben bitte bitte bitte bitte das ist ja
eh das die beste diese Verpackungen auch
ne guck mal hier ist extra was Z
aufreißen me dann rollen die schon raus
du hast eiglich Kühlschrank der ein
bisschen schräg gestellt wird und dann
na ja guck den Kühlschrank an also in
Deutschland passt das leider nicht dann
kannst du dir die Dinger reinknallen
letzten Artikel die D haben also volo
ist so ein Ding das ging ein bisschen
durch Medien in USA weil 14% Alkohol und
750 ml ir umgerechnet drin das reicht
schon um sich da kannst umzusppern genau
und deswegen klar weil die College K
sich dann ihre sapichen damit machen
also Drink responsible wenn um Alkohol
geht find das so spannend hier ne für
dich ist das ja jetzt seit 20 Jahren de
dein täglich Brot aber ich finde das so
faszinierend irgendwie dass man diese
amerikanischen Produkte hier auf
deutschenem Boden hat einfach nur so gut
weil du halt rüber holst ne aber sonst
das existiert ja alles nicht in
Deutschland ich will nicht dein Lager
le geil muss es ja Essen und Trinken
ne so haben wir denn noch hier kommen
wir jetzt in die S genau hier hab
ein hier auch ein paar Sachen rauskramen
so Sorten wie hier oc und
min P ein Pack ein ich glaub die Jungs
im Büro werden uns lieben und hassen
schau mal hier was ich hier gefunden hab
diese twinkies die habe ich auch schon
gesehen ja ja me davon hast
noch geil hab ich mitgebracht
oder Pass auf das ist der Tequila von
The
Rock so der ist richtig richtig gut mach
Cocktails an in in
köle also wirosado ist auch der
der die sind alle gut ich habe mich über
alles gefreut aber über the tequil das
ist schon das ganz besonderes si auch
der Arbeit dahinter ne alle Artikel
müssen gelabelt werden mit
inhalsetiketten mit fand die ganzen
Getränke also da denkt das nichtil
Alkohol hat erstens kein
Haltbarkeitsdatum und klar was drin ist
aber das ist halt echt eine Menge Arbeit
die hiniten wird alles überklebt alles
klebt wir haben Behinderten Werkstatt
mit der zusammenarbeiten die direkt um
die Ecke ist also Teil machen wir selber
Teil mit Werkstatt auch schon mehrere
Jahre tatsächlich und das ist läuft sehr
sehr gut ja werden das beste
Wochenende auch geil hier icebreakers
die habe ich immer in Denis corner
gekauft icebreakers beste Leben guck mal
es geht weiter da kommen die tuis noch
von der anderen Seite tuis blue heat
tuis fuego also wir können theoretisch
drei Videos drehen aus dies wenn ihr da
was tolles rausaubern könnt und ein
bisschen austogen würde ich mich freuen
tatsächlich ich glaube wir werden Spaß
haben wir gehen jetzt ins Büro testen
das ganze und vielen vielen Dank noch
mal das ist wirklich ein absoluter
Kindheit viel Spaß beim probieren danke
schön was für ein Ehrenmann ist bitte
Otto ich glaube wir haben jetzt genug
Süßigkeiten und Getränke für die
nächsten drei Jahre hier im Büro aber
wir haben ein kleiner Auswahl
zusammengestellt von dem was wir
bekommen haben ich weiß gar nicht so
richtig wo ich anfangen soll weil ich
will einfach alles probieren irgendwie
komm ich schaue mir ich schau mal nach
links nach rechts snapple komm ich nehme
mal so ein snapple das ist so geil es
sind auch so viele Sachen die ich selbst
in Amerika noch nicht mal gesehen oder
probiert habe das ist irgendwie so ein
fruit Punch 220 calories per bottle ist
jetzt nicht gerade wenig ne also es wird
so so gemartet als etwas sehr gesundes
da hat auch viel Zucker aber ist
natürlich aus Konzentrat und so bin mal
gespannt wie so ein snapple schmeckt
raspberry Peach auf euch Schallert ein
gut die Birne Weg man stellt sich aber
viel mehr special vor als es eigentlich
ist also irgendwie schmeckt es so es
könnte auch ein deutscher Saft sein das
ist irgendwie wir werden so ein bisschen
beurteilen welche Sache sich vielleicht
lohnt aus Amerika zu holen und welche so
ein bisschen normal sind snapple ist für
mich persönlich kann auch ein Deutschen
billigsaft trinken twinkies wollte ich
die ganze Zeit schon probieren es sieht
krass aus finde ich es sieht so aus wie
so die ultimative Verkörperung der
Industrie einfach so weißes weiches Brot
mit so einer Cremefüllung wahrscheinlich
ist es auch genau das aber wir sollten
es unbedingt probieren um es
herauszufinden ich find auch das
Branding sieht so aus ob es schon so 20
Jahre genauso ist aber es ist auch
zeitlos es ist zeitlos das ist einfach
ein geiles cleanes Branding und Branding
ist das was die amerikanischen Produkte
häufig ausmacht also öffnen wir unsere
twinkies von der Marke hostes si
eentlich ein bisschen aus wie so ein
madlin ne also würdest du in Frankreich
auch bekommen aber cream filling ist es
natürlich was es aus macht ne und hier
sieht man schon cream filling ist auf
jeden Fall zu genüge drin machen einmal
auf
und irgendwie verrückt wenn man sich
überlegt dass das in Amerika gebacken
und produziert wurde dass ich jetzt in
Deutschland einfach reinbeißen kann auf
euch das hat so LOWI ist das so ein
Wolke Schaldämpfer an eine Sache
erinnert mich das es ist so eine ganz
entfernte Erinnerung das ist so mixmax
mixmax ich muss es mal googel ich Ken
den Namen aber ich weiß nicht ob das
mixmax ist aber wahrscheinlich so
Rechtecke ne das hat so mehr so eine
schokoladenummantelung ja aber dieser
Geschmack ist das ungef das in
Cappuccino dippen und ich glaube das
wird noch doppelt so geil oh ja also not
bad muss ich sagen in Amerika gibt's
auch häufig solche Geschichten hier so
String Candy oder so lange Süßigkeiten
die irgendwie eine lustige Form haben
das hier ist jetzt leffy teffy so wie es
auch gesehen hatten gab's ja von leffy
teffy diese bananenbonbons das hier ist
jetzt einfach so ein leffy teffy
Stab wie so ein Zauberstab zwei
Geschmacksrichtung try ich glaub ich
werde an Verfettung sterben am Ende von
diesem Video oh ja das schmeckt so wie
ma oder wie ma aber ein geileres ma und
das will was heißen ma ist iconic das
schmeckt ein bisschen nach Plastik finde
ich schmeckt wirklich ein bisschen so
wie wenn man irgendwie so eine
Luftmatratze oder Schwimmflügel
irgendwie SAS gelastischen Plastik so
was man so aufpusten mus probier mal
hier das Pretzel m& MS mit Brezel
ummantelte M&Ms ganz normal auf dem
ersten Blick ja auf dem ersten Blick das
normalste der Welt probier mal so clean
aufzubeißen das ist halt schon ja so ein
Kügelchen aus Salz brzel inen drin das
hat einen geilen Geschmack das hat so
diese die Lauge von der salzbrezel und
irgendwie so dieser laugengeschmack mit
dem Salz und der süßen Schokolade
schmeckt halt irgendwie richtig oha
sieht übelst geil aus aber diese minzöle
die da raus knallen sind wirklich brutal
greife jetzt einmal rein und nehme die
M&Ms es schmeckt wie Bremer Gluten nur
nicht ganz so süß so Freunde jetzt
schaut euch bitte einfach mal an wie
genial hier alles gemacht ist hier an
der Seite ist die Öffnung Eindrücken
hochziehen dann öffnet man sich das hier
ach das kannst du sogar wegnehmen ne und
dann kannst du immer gerade wenn der
Kühlschrank so wie Otto mein so ein
bisschen geneigt ist nimmst du dir eins
raus und das nächste rollt direkt nach
das halt da muss man sich auch möglichst
wenig bewegen um sein AW cream Soda zu
bekommen
ne Werbung Werbung no Werbung
s Arizona PL
TA weniger schlimm als gedacht ich habe
mir so mit dem Todesstoß gerechnet wenn
ich ganz ehrlich bin wie gut schmeckt
das der otto hat gut gesagt ich meine er
kennt seine Produkte der verkauft die
seit 20 Jahren es schmeckt so wie eine
amerikanische Version vonudler von also
ich sag ganz ehrlich ich fin ich fin
nicht schlecht ich will aber nicht die
probieren sondern ich wollte die hier
probieren weil ich find die sehen noch
viel kranker aus das sind einfach so big
chewy Nerds haben mir gemerkt normale
Nerds sind im Prinzip einfach nur schlau
ja Bruder die sehen aus wie so
Plastikspielzeug das kann man nicht
essen ja das sieht real Talk aus wie so
Spielzeug ich finde das auch wirklich
bemerkenswert gerade von mir selbst dass
ich mir das einfach so gedankenlos
reinschraube aber ich glaube genau darum
geht es dass man einfach Kopf aus und
Nerds rein auch hier erinnert mich das
wieder total an irgendwas so diese
Traubenzucker säurehaltige Geschichte
außenrum in drin so kauonbon mäßig das
irgendwie geil lelebt so in den Zehen
das irgendwie geil also definitiv geiler
als die normalen Nerds muss mein alten
meinen alten Freund anzapfen was ich
Otto erzählt habe stimmt übrigens zu
100% dass ich so von moneyby inspiriert
damals übelst hängen geblieben bin auf
diesem ganzen Amerika Film es war
einfach geil so der hat so eine
Faszination dafür geteilt und er teilt
sie immer noch mittlerweile mag ich ihn
nur nicht mehr weil er nicht auf meine
Einladung antwortet für einlicher Kopf
so das hat mich einfach ab das hat mich
einfach mitgenommen so das hat mir so
ein richtiges Fernweh geschaffen also
ich habe so re so im Rahmen meiner
Möglichkeiten habe ich so davon geträumt
mal so nach Amerika zu gehen Fanta grape
grape flavored Soda with other natural
flavors das ist immer so geil da steht
so drauf es ist ein bisschen
Traubenaroma drin Fanta
grape so riecht für mich Amerika
also es ist einfach geile Scheiße Alter
ich Schw dir blue tuckies ich glaube es
gibt bestimmt wieder Leute we einfach so
ein Hyp hat die auf das Video geklickt
haben gesehen haben blueies und jetzt
wissen wollen was ich dazu
sage da sind sie drin es ist wieder so
krass ne aber diese Faszination die
funktioniert ja nicht nur in Amerika geh
auf tiktok und überall siehst du blue
tuckies so auch dieses ganze sweet Ding
funktioniert ja in ganz Deutschland ja
wie schmecken jetzt blue tuckys so
gerollte Mais Chips mit blue one Lake
steht da einfach nur drauf was auch
immer das heißt also blue tuckys da geht
schon viel ab die sind vor allem sauer
weil s so ganz viel Limetten seasoning
haben die haben eine Schärfe die sind
crunchy die sind salzig da ist schon
ganz viel dabei was Spaß macht und dazu
kommt dann halt noch dass die Dinger
blau sind deine Zunge färben gefärbt
noch nicht ganz zeig deine Zunge ich
ja färben deine Zunge das ist einfach
ein pun Snack aber ganz ehrlich wir
wissen dann halt auch am Ende des Tages
nicht was wir uns da reinschrauben so
wirklich ne ich habe jetzt so viel
durcheinander getrunken ich glaube ich
muss mal den den Magen ein bisschen
frisch
bekommen also da muss ich noch mal sagen
noch mal gesondert ein großes Dankeschön
an Otto das ist ein ein eine literfasche
vom Reposado von The Rock Tequila der
soll wirklich sehr gut sein ist auch
nicht ganz günstig das Ding deshalb Kuss
und Gruß geht noch mal
raus yes
sir das ist so brutal ne guter Tequila
ist ein weltenunterschied zu diesem Ding
mit dem roten Hut was man kennt du
riechst an dieser Flasche du riechst
süße du riechst Honig du riechst Limette
und Rauch musst eigentlich auch schon
fast probieren er
oder
wie mein Bauch sich so reingegrummelt
hat aber sorry was ist das für ein
geiles Design irgendwie mag ich wo
dieses Video sich hinentwickelt wir sind
einfach wir nur die Idee lass zu
autoofahren dann gibt uns a die fetteste
Tour ich teste mich einmal quer durch
jetzt trinken wir noch Tequila das
riecht wirklich so süß salute haben wir
ja gelernt ne salute es schmeckt nach
all dem was ich gerade gesagt habe sauf
den bitte nicht an karneewal nein Honig
Lim schöne Schärfe hinten raus aber
nicht so dieses ganz sprittige falls ihr
in Zukunft mehr Tequila Reviews sehen
wollt dann schreibt in die Kommentare so
wir haben jetzt von allem ein bisschen
was getestet aber der otto hat uns hier
noch eine ordentliche Box gegeben wo so
von allem ein bisschen was drin ist auch
paar Kamelle noch also was mich hiervon
wirklich noch interessiert sind diese
Elm Joy Dinger weil die sehen auch so
aus als GST die schon immer ich habe es
aber noch nie getestet deshalb let's go
sind es so Bounties mit einer Mandel
oben drauf das ist halt erm und Joy ne
erm Joy mandelspaß halt ne es sind es
ist Bounty mit einer Mandel oben drauf
geil so Freunde ich glaube wir haben
nicht nur etwas gelernt darüber wie es
ist amerikanische Produkte nach
Deutschland zu importieren sondern auch
eine vielfall von Produkten testen
dürfen deshalb vielen Dank noch mal an
Otto das war eine ganz spontane Nummer
dass wir vorbeigeschaut haben zum
Abschluss probiere ich jetzt noch mal
den forlcoo 14% Alkohol auf diese
riesenfasche steht nicht mal den
Millilitern drauf aber ich schätze das
sind so 750 auf euch ne ich fin
schrecklich also danke fürs zuschauen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder
bis dahin ciao ciao geil